so far we've already established but if
you want to select a bunch of things and
you want them in order right firstly we
gave that a special name we called them
permutations if you have n objects
and you have K spots to fill so you want
to put you want you want K of those
objects right ah you got two situations
you have you got with replacement or
without replacement but we've noticed
like the object and you put you're
putting them in two spots then firing
away the more common situation is
without replacement like it's it's I
can't put this pin in another spot one
time put it down
okay so then we developed this formula
how to do in factorials right and we
called it and P okay right yeah even
though the reason why I would use this
mpk notation is so we don't have to
worry about the factorials it's still
important that you get what it actually
is what's what's the fraction what's on
the top n factorial good and then we're
dividing by it might say it back to a
right why was it isaac n minus K is it
so the idea was you had your spots by
the way I keep doing this I don't like
getting sick of it it's such a useful
tool like 9 times out of 10 when someone
has come to me you know as you're
working along you're like I have a
question right nine times out of ten my
explanation begins well think about and
then I draw this either on the board or
in my head right because it's just such
a useful way to work out what's going on
and why is my answer wrong okay so you
start off with n different choices
because that's how many objects you've
got to choose from right say 10 right
and then you go well 9
than eight and then seven and then the
thing you have to divide by the number
of factorial that's missing is n minus K
factorial in this case I guess it would
be 10 minus 4 which is 6 factorial so
we're okay with that right now the
examples we looked at
where order matters right what were the
examples we looked at things like a
password these water kind of matters in
a pass through it other things like say
a trifecta 1st 2nd 3rd those kinds of
situations order matters okay but lots
of the time and remember we're in the
context of probabilities right lots of
the time order does not matter ok so
here are my if you are selecting a team
for sport right I mean just don't worry
for a second about sports with positions
matter I'm just like which four of you
are going to be on this team and which
four of you want to be on that team
right teams the order doesn't really
matter all that much I just want to know
who the people off ok or committees
right everyone's going to be the same on
this community doesn't matter which
order you get picked in okay and when
we're thinking about probability for
example consider a question like a coin
gets flipped right so we've we've looked
at these and we drew probability trees
or dot diagrams and so on and one of the
classic questions would be ok what's the
probability that you get one head and
one tail right if I if I hit twice okay
now you don't care whether the head
comes first or whether it comes second
right head tail and tail head are the
same with regard to which ones you're
interested in right so in lots of
situations related to probability we're
in this kind of care we're not in this
care we don't worry about water
so therefore in a in unordered
summations
how can we relate this to what we
already know
okay well let's think let's think of
them let's think of this example here
okay so suppose ten nine eight seven
well okay now let's make it a zero
there's there's a password okay so I've
got a password there now if I don't
worry about the order okay that means
that if I swap some of the numbers okay
for example if instead of this I have
let's switch those two if those are the
same right it's the same selection
without worrying about water okay you
can see that there's going to be more
than two ways to rearrange these same
four numbers right and it'll be the same
set of four numbers just in a different
one which I don't worry about now the
question is how many how many different
ways can I rearrange these four and I
still have the same four numbers
yeah it's just four factorial it's four
pick four right so hold on a second if I
come to you with all of these different
permutations we already worked out there
are 10,000 of them right and I say look
here my 10,000 different passwords and
you start to flick through you start to
look through the list and you like hold
on these set of four numbers you don't
care about the order is set four numbers
are the same as this one which will be
the same as you know if I switch these
two numbers or suppose these two numbers
and you'll be like look there are four
times three times two there's like 24
passwords
mm-hm sets of four numbers that are all
the same right and you repeat it every
time you get a new set of four numbers
right I go one two three four there will
be 24 of my permutations that for your
intents and purposes I don't care about
they'll all be the same there'll be
another 24 of these and another 24 of
the next step so I'm over counting how
much have I over counted by I've ever
counted by that 24 that 4 factorial okay
and obviously if I had a five digit
password there will be even more ways
for me to rearrange these and you don't
care because you don't care about the
order okay so therefore if I don't care
about the order if all I want to do is
combine them in some sort of way and
that's what this is about
this is our counterpart to the idea of
permutations where order matters
combining like the picture I have is
like in a recipe you know combine all of
the wet elements in a bowl you don't
care where they go just chuck them all
in okay if I don't care then I over
counted this this thing is wrong it
gives me too many okay so the number of
ways we'll start with NPK but I have to
divide by something right now in this
case I divided by 4 factorial why did I
divide by 4 factorial because that was
the number of ways I I rearranged and
you're like I don't care just give it to
me just give me the numbers I don't
worry about the order okay I have a kind
of my full factorial that's the number
of spots I have to put them in right
that was K that's why it's 4 factor with
its K factorial so I've over counted by
that factor does that make sense
so that's how we go from my list where I
care about all of cuz I'm OCD to your
list where you like to I want to know
which numbers they are what it doesn't
matter so therefore of course you can go
back to this factorial notation and you
can say so I've run out of space so I'm
gonna do something notice go across the
board you got this guy n factorial on n
minus K vector and then you're going to
divide again by K vector and that'll fix
you up okay now I don't mind about the
order
now just like NPK this is a really
important and very common scenario to
worry about right and so that's why it
gets its own notation which we've
already developed before in a completely
different context okay but this is NCCAM
by the way the C stands for combination
and the P stands for permutations right
but because combination and permutation
are long words to say that's all you
often say n pick K and n choose K even
though that's a complete coincidence
no one designed it with that in mind
they designed it with these words in
mind but you'll hear people say it like
that